guys like no spice world I would say I
went to the cinema to see spice world
it's like high-speed collision between a
Jaguar and a jaywalking soccer hooligan
I can only imagine that that's Kingsman
the Secret Service
[Applause]
it may be stupid but it's never dull
it's got to be a repeat I haven't been
in that many movies
Kingsman again Secret Service is it in
Alton one
no it's one of mine lovely Oh what else
have I been in I've been in I was in
that Robin Hood movie yeah yeah I can't
really argue with that one Canyon an
ingenious mixture of themes from
narrative sources as ancient and varied
as Hamlet the Old Testament the Odyssey
was very grand and complimentary that's
not something I mean from the three
people in the audience danced at the
finale two male and female so it
couldn't have sucked that's not really
that's not really nice is it that's kind
of it sort of sounds good but it's not
it's sing Oh Tommy
spy skills guys like no spice world I
would say I went to the cinema to see
spice world that's so cute I don't
remember that bear was probably too busy
focusing on the Spice Girls and this is
a gilded hamster wheel of a movie a
gilded helps the world that would sort
of suggests that it's repetitive as
Kings in the Golden Circle
well I'm sorry Geoffrey McNab what day
is it today Wednesday exactly it doesn't
quite jell it's admirable that the film
made of such weird ingredients is even
vaguely palatable but it couldn't
possibly be anything I'm in good
is it Gnomeo and Juliet come up me hello
it's all fairly excessive and far from
subtle but in this case the taste would
have been wildly inappropriate and a
fearful drag no repeaters billionaire
boys club
Oh Tommy a massive vat of hot cocoa with
a mountain of whipped cream on top
sweeten warm and maybe the mission to
satisfy everyone who takes a sip is that
Eddie even without me yeah I quite like
that
that's a bit like too much of a good
thing that doesn't it
each to their own I ceased smiling like
a big dummy only during the two points
of the film which had been engineered to
make me cry at which point
voila tears Eddie Eagle again Oh sing
[Music]
that's it
[Music]